this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because advertisements suck
non-minimalists
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life
with less my name's joshua fields
milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus and
together we are the minimalists today
we're going to talk about lifestyle
clutter we're going to talk about all
the extra things we do
and the extraneous activities
obligations
and tasks we commit to that make our
lives more complicated
and so why not have ben greenfield here
to do that that's right returning
champion is here
that's right i live a very uncomplicated
uncluttered life
a perfect guest well i tell you what um
i'll tell you on the surface ben your
life does seem to be
cluttered if i were just to look at your
surface a lot of obligations a lot of
things you do you're very productive
but i think that live an intentional
life if not a minimal life even
because the things that you do when we
talk about minimalism what we're really
talking about is the intentional use of
our resources
part of that's our money but then our
time our attention
our energy and you use all of those
things intentionally you might use them
differently from
how ryan and i were using them we would
use them but you
use your resources in a way that adds
value to your life
as opposed to being you know passive and
just constantly
pacifying yourself with with
distractions
and so um obviously never seen me around
a pile of rib eye steaks because i can
get distracted for a few hours
i would call it focused well we're here
on the
certain things that can derail me uh
we're here on the occasion of your new
book that came out boundless
it is uh i have our books on top of
yours and
my god this is like ryan you need your
help
to show it on youtube i feel like that
book is anti-minimalist
my apologies gentlemen i broke all of
your rules you know what i just we just
decluttered a bunch of books in my
household and that's we kept that one
because it's uh it's like a fitness
bible almost that's what you should have
called it the fitness well it actually
is in a way decluttering because you
no longer need ten books you've just got
one absolutely you don't need your
immunity book or your fat loss book your
muscle gain book etc
yeah it is a large stolen one when it
showed up you guys just gave me a brand
new sales pitch
when he showed up on the doorstep the uh
the ups person
dropped it and made a very large sound i
thought it was an earthquake for a
moment
i was thinking about this book i was
going through it by the way sorry to
interrupt there was an earthquake last
night yeah
yeah all right i thought i was just
feeling things my bed was in
the hotel was cleaning the the carpets
late at night or something like that
and you know i forgot i was in
california yeah i woke up sniper i woke
up to my wife she was like
what are you doing over there i'm like
nothing i think it's an earthquake
like they gave me the vibrating bed and
i randomly figured out how to turn it on
at 4 30 a.m
what are you doing over there go back to
sleep honey
you know i i was up riding and um i was
editing this book we're working on
and i i had just finished this really
profound line all of a sudden the earth
started
shaking i'm like yeah i think i got it
right finally that sounds about right
um then i was thinking about this book
boundless
if i were to rename it not that i would
because i think it was a phenomenal
title but
i i think of it as just how to live we
have a friend
uh derek sivers who has this new book
that's coming out called how to live so
um it's a phenomenal title but
there's something in here for just about
everyone if you have a question
about life health i mean the
we'll talk a bit about the book itself
in a little bit but the subtitle here
is upgrade your brain optimize your body
and defy
aging so you it's really mind body
spirit as well right well originally i
wanted to write a book about anti-aging
and longevity you know what the
so-called blue zones
are doing where all these people are
living a disproportionately long period
of time
uh you know drinking tannin and
polyphenol and flavonol rich teas and
kombuchas and beverages and
herding goats and climbing mountains and
being with people and getting lots of
sunshine and you know what
what's their diet comprised of you know
largely a you know
lower carb mediterranean approach in
many of these places with with legume
intake and a
wide variety of plants and herbs and
spices and
you know how they're training how
they're moving how they're lifting
the problem is though once i started to
go down
all the different biological pathways to
aging
it turns out you gotta include some
stuff on immunity you need to include
some information
on the gut on on the the blood brain
barrier
um neurotransmitter balance on the type
of muscle fiber composition that lends
itself
best to living a long time and being
functional and it kind of turned into
more of a manual for the body and the
brain
and there was so much that i kept coming
across from
gratitude belief in a higher power
prayer
relationship silence solitude meditation
that was also woven into the lifestyle
practices of so many healthy people
that the spiritual component just kept
coming up over and over again
and so multiple chapters have have that
part
as well which is honestly i think one of
the more
neglected components especially in
physical culture
you know this idea that you have this
you know invisible spark inside of you
that you must fuel and feed by
sitting cross-legged with your eyes
closed you know in a fasted state
speaking to god or praying or focusing
on your breath work a lot of people
don't want
to hear that that they just need to slow
down and stop and take a breath
but there's there's a lot of that woven
into the book as well so yeah it took on
a life
of its own but originally i just wanted
to be about
anti-aging and longevity i feel like you
can you can
this is one of those books you can read
it all the way through or you can use it
as
this sort of encyclopedia for living
better
in a way and so speaking of living
better we do want to talk about
lifestyle clutter today this is a
listener driven
show so we'll dive into some questions
we have here from the audience let's
start with amber
in atlanta georgia how do you let go of
limiting beliefs
i'm an aspiring artist and as josh may
know that means i've been
drawing pretty infrequently lately
i have this belief i must make a profit
from my art and it's
stopped me dead in my tracks but worst
of all it's kept me from feeling happy
in my everyday life
how do you minimize your inner critic
now ben i think this is fascinating
because we often
conflate sort of creativity with needing
to make a profit right away but
sometimes that actually spoils it
it it does look the
the most satisfied and fulfilled that
you will feel in life
is if you're living out your life's true
purpose right we're all born with a
unique skill set
and i think that everyone should have
some kind of single succinct purpose
statement
the thing that gets you out of bed in
the morning you know what the japanese
would call ikigai
or in italy it would be called the plan
davida but this idea
that you know why it is that you are
here and what your unique
purpose is you know both of my children
have purpose statements one is to
create art that elicits powerful
emotions from people
right that's that's his purpose
statement um
mine is to uh to read write
learn teach sing speak compete and
create
in full presence and selfless love to
the glory of god
and that's my purpose that's what rips
me out of bed
in the morning one very important
component
of your purpose statement is once you
have found it once you have formed it
and you do this by thinking about the
things that you really enjoyed to do
when you were a kid
the things that make time go by very
quickly for you now put you in the
so-called
zone the unique skills that you have
that allow things to come easy to you
and in when you've identified all of
those things you can piece together
a purpose statement based on what it is
that you're actually naturally good at
and feel a great deal of joy from when
you're engaged in that
but if you hone your purpose statement
down you have the perfect purpose
statement and then you go forth into the
world and your goal with that purpose
statement is maslow's hierarchy
right i'm going to use this purpose
statement to get my house to feed myself
and my family to make a lot of money to
get a better car
have a bigger home etc that
that's pretty unfulfilling versus this
idea
that you think i have my purpose
statement i'm going to go out and
love as many other people as possible
with that purpose statement
right and i've even couched that into my
own statement you don't have to do that
but you know
in full presence and selfless love for
others is is kind of tailed at the end
of my purpose statement because i want
that constant reminder
but you find your purpose statement and
then you go out into the world
and you love other people with that
purpose statement so
uh so uh amber is the is the gal called
in
yeah she if she creates art
and she has an avatar she has that
person in mind who's going to be seeing
her art
and being moved being emoted having some
kind of a connection to her art some
kind of inspiration you know what
what is the end goal of what her art is
going to do
for people i guarantee that if you are
creating your business around a service
for other people
and loving other people the money will
come if you come out from the other
angle
i i want to do this to make money you'll
often get disconnected from your true
self you'll hold yourself back from
creating what you actually want to
create
because you will experience what one of
the more common regrets of the dying is
living your life creating or doing what
the world expects you or what you think
the world expects you to do versus
staying true to your authentic self
stay true to your authentic self love
other people with your purpose
and the money will come yeah there's
this thought of you know
ryan and i will sometimes say that good
businesses make money great businesses
make a difference and
right now amber is striving through this
thought process because she's been
acculturated to believe that i have to
make money first it's the primary driver
of doing what i'm going to do
well you're striving for at best a good
business
but a great business as you said it
helps helps other people solve
their problems now it can you can do
that through art you can do that through
writing you can do it through plumbing
right there are different ways to solve
people's problems i loved
your purpose statement because there was
nothing that even hinted toward
earning more revenue or maximizing cash
flow or anything
like reach one billion customers in ten
years like i i don't think those are
those are bad objectives
to be on a business blueprint for
example or
even as part of the the core purpose of
a business
uh you know having having some kind of
metrics that you want to reach i think
that's smart
but in terms of the value that you want
to deliver it it really should be
for other people the the other thing
that's important for a creator
for an artist like amber is to realize
that it's okay to outsource a
lot of the business and the financial
decisions
and the delivery and the publishing
and the shipping to a team thus
equipping and enabling you and freeing
you
to create i've personally found that as
i add team members to my team and i'm
able to
just focus on the writing and not think
okay who's processing the credit card if
someone wants to go
buy a book from this article i wrote and
you know who's
monitoring whatever instagram
advertisements for this
product that i have in my mind that i
want to create if i free myself from
that by surrounding me with other people
who do a lot of the business and the
financial stuff
it allows me to go into creator mode and
not have those little thoughts ticking
away at the back of my mind
i'm trying to create i'm trying to write
because amber is trying to make art
and so that's a big part of it too is
you want to outsource some of this stuff
to a team
who can do some of that thinking for you
and in an era
of virtual assistance and you know
mechanical
turks i think they're called nowadays
it's a it's a term used to describe you
know people who
do things for you on the internet it's
pretty easy scalable
and cost effective to find people who
can do things like your
landing page your credit card pro you
know all of that
is pretty achievable in this day and age
i like i like the advice to yeah focus
on
creating it it sounds to me like you're
saying focus on creating more and maybe
on the results less even though i mean
we should care about the results
but if you're just focusing on the
results it's going to stunt your
creation
what i like about your uh your purpose
ben is
it's it's very lasered but it's also in
a way very broad
because you can in many ways fulfill
that purpose it doesn't mean that you
have to be
a an author who gives great advice on
health
there are many things that you can do to
fulfill that purpose so that would be
something i would recommend is when
someone is coming up with this this
purpose statement
it doesn't have to be like oh i have to
be an artist to make money
uh keep it as broad as possible the the
statement could be
i want to create work that is going to
inspire others or move people
emotionally
and uh yeah i think that'll help take a
little bit of the pressure off
from from amber here ryan the there's
the thing about when we're talking about
clutter here because
what i hear in her question even and ben
you tell me what you think about this
but
really what you're talking about is
taking some of these obligations that
she doesn't look forward to you're just
talking about taking those off the table
and and maybe at first you don't have
the ability to do that you know everyone
who starts off as an entrepreneur or a
solopreneur
you might have to do everything on your
own for a while just like ryan and i did
when we started the minimalists a decade
ago it was literally just the two of us
remember going to bookstores and like
measuring the margins
oh yeah yeah we literally did everything
we were driving around his toyota
corolla from bookstore to bookstore and
we would do events you know selling our
book
and and so like sometimes but eventually
you'll get to a point where
in order to add value to people's lives
you have to take some of that clutter
away
you do and and i do not want to paint
this all
as you know roses and sunshine and
unicorn farts like like there's some
hard work that has to be done i
experienced the same thing when i was a
personal trainer
you know working 10 to 12 hour days with
clients in a gym
you know counting reps and running
people up the stairs and
you know and demonstrating push-ups and
squats i would get
home typically around 9 or 10 p.m i
would have a quick dinner with my wife
and then i would be up until about 2 a.m
programming my website creating php
scripts creating the the credit card
processing forms
doing the adobe indesign work on my
self-published books
and i was sleeping about four to five
hours a night for a good three years
to lay the foundation there are probably
things that i was doing then that even
then i could have outsourced
but there there is
there there is a time when you are gonna
find yourself
working a little bit more than you would
like to in order to lay the foundation
for you to then say you know have enough
money set aside to bring on your first
virtual assistant or to outsource your
first project but
you know again 99 designs squarespace
and all these websites that make it
pretty achievable to do it at a low cost
dictates that
you know you're not going to have to
moonlight for the next decade but
yeah there may be a few months or even a
couple of years where you at you know
life gets gets tough and and i can tell
you that
most successful people have had to put
in the hard work
and you know for me in the fitness
industry that's one of the most
annoying things when you see some kid
pop up on instagram with a nice body
and this you know crappy little pdf that
they made for the workouts that
that they did you know they're they're
on hormones or andro or steroids or
whatnot and
they've got everything photoshopped they
they have almost zero certifications or
degrees or
you know an online moonlit you know
personal training certification
and you know all of a sudden they've got
300 000 followers and
they're filthy stinking rich even though
they never really put in that much of
the hard work there's some of those
people out there
um but i think ultimately in the long
run
um society kind of filters out
who actually knows their stuff and who
gets results versus who's just a pretty
face who's a flash in the pan
yeah by the way if you are completely
careless like that and you sell someone
a pdf for twenty dollars they're not
gonna come back to you not gonna
you you've lost all the trust with them
and so part of that purpose statement
can actually
have something to do with establishing
establishing trust
with people so that you you're adding so
much value to their lives that they're
eager to pay you in some ways and we do
that with our patreon
a large portion of our audience listens
to the podcast for free but then
there are you know five or six thousand
people who listen on patreon
and they give us the opportunity to pay
sean pay jordan pay yes
value value so when i write an article
you'll often find at the end of my
articles on my website
there are opportunities to purchase
things like i hope you enjoyed this
article if you want more you know
grab my book because there's there's you
know 18 other tips
on this same topic of say fat loss in my
book or
you know now that i've taught you all
about you know curcumin
or or turmeric here's the opportunity to
actually grab a product that i created
that will help your your
joints or something like that however
whenever i'm writing an article or
creating a piece like that my goal is
for someone to walk away from having
read that a better person a more
educated person
i want their lives to be better whether
or not they purchase
anything at all same with my podcast all
i want to do is help people
if there are things in there you know go
to the show notes and grab this from
amazon and it supports the podcast or
you know buy this supplement or grab
this book
fine but the goal is to deliver value
and to educate that that's always at the
top of the totem pole and if people want
to buy stuff based on that
great but the number one priority is to
create value
and if you get that backwards you're not
just screwing
other people you're screwing yourself
because if you're not if you're not
serving those people then well if they
don't feel served they don't feel
compelled to
right you know to stick around oh yeah
we see this in in even you know
internet marketing you know long video
sales letters
or um or pitches for products etc
the best ones have a great deal of
education built in
if if you read them they'll always start
by explaining explaining explaining and
there's this molecule on that molecule
or
you know this technique or that
technique or this approach or that
approach
and then at the very end or towards the
end that's when they say and here's a
solution that ties together all these
things you know and there's
there's even you know people who sell
products online with
with an exact script an exact sequence
you know first you lay down the value
here
and then you explain some of the
components of your product then you have
the testimonials etc
but all the best ones start with educate
the customer give them
mad value yeah what do you think about
uh
suggesting amber kind of shift her
reward so right now
her reward is making money so instead of
having that as the goal yeah it should
be to yeah move people with her art or
uh maybe yeah i don't know just
something that isn't so
driven uh by this specific result
because i feel like when we do that
you go from like getting to do something
to having to do something
because right now if we can weigh the
magic wand and like give her okay we'll
pay you you know
a dollar for every single piece of art
you put out i mean that's just going to
make her
do something over and over again because
she's expecting that dollar
but instead of getting the yeah they get
to do it it's
now i have to do it to to get this
dollar for each piece and the result of
that
can be pretty much the complete opposite
of what ryan holliday dictates in his
book the perennial best seller
you wind up creating let's say for me as
an author i could pump out
five to seven dollar pdfs and cheap
kindle books on amazon
all day long and i could profit heavily
from that
and at the end of the day you know
thinking forward as
as as dark as it may seem to my deathbed
i don't see myself being incredibly
fulfilled you know with
seven six pack abs you know 50 page
downloadable pdfs
on amazon or something like that i want
to write something
that is that that's big that's epic
that's going to stick that people
come back and return to over and over
again and
again if you're caught up in the
money-making part of things
you can as you've just alluded to ryan
you can you can create these whatever
one dollar pieces of art and sell them
all day long and make a profit
but i think that creating true art
creating masterpieces is
far more fulfilling at the end of the
day and so that's another thing to bear
in mind
is that with profit as the primary
incentive
you'll often create slightly more
shallow less meaningful products just
you can get them out there
ship and pay the bills yeah well the
opposite of a shallow product for sure
is this uh boundless book amber i'm
going to send you a copy actually i'll
send you this copy
maybe we'll even get ben to sign it for
you i'll devalue
and there you go let me ask you um how
how
how big was this book before the editing
started was it like
twice as twice as much like did you have
to cut a lot to get it manuscript
that i turned into the publisher was
1200 pages
those three years of working with a
couple of research assistants a
scientific editor
uh the the publishing companies
editorial team
and uh so we cut about 600 pages because
the the current
version is 650 pages however i didn't
want to kiss my babies goodbye
so i put all the extra content that got
cut from the book
onto kind of a hidden resources section
of
the website for the book and so when
people get the book they can go and put
in their little amazon order number or
their order number
and get access to all the hidden content
but that
that was tough because the way i write
books is i generally have a shared cloud
drive in google
and then a separate folder for each
chapter of the book with all the
research all the references the
podcasts the audiobooks the people i
want to interview the ideas i have
there's a separate folder in
that main google drive for each separate
chapter of the book
and so it winds up turning into a little
bit of a beast over time but at the same
time
as you revise you have the previous
revision this paragraph got cut but
we've got
you know the very first version of the
chapter that was written and so
for me kissing my baby's goodbye
wasn't as painful because i knew they'd
they'd live on that you know they're not
in the actual published manuscript but
they're still
online so that kind of freed me up a
little bit to have a little less pain
about the editing process amber enjoy
your copy of
boundless we got a question from joseph
in new york city
i'm a senior in high school and um
attending the the course of my my career
at high school
i i have a lot of time i'm just figuring
out what i want to do
with my life and everything that i'm
going forward so just what i'm doing if
you have any suggestions to find
meaning and purpose and and now that i
have this clean statement
going to college or what i should really
be heading for
all right ben so joseph here he has a
different kind of clutter he has the
the too many options clutter the paradox
of choice he's
graduate of high school congratulations
for asking this question right now by
the way not waiting until you're
30 like me and ryan to start asking this
question and
and instead we just sort of let the
winds of consumerism and the business
world push us in a particular direction
but you're asking this question now how
do i be more intentional how do i figure
out my meaning and purpose
well we fortunately touched a little bit
on this
in replying to amber's question but to
get more specific about your purpose
i mentioned thinking back to what you
liked to do when you were a kid
that's you what did i like to do i like
to read i like to write i like to learn
i like to teach things to other kids in
the neighborhood like how to burn ant
piles with a magnifying glass or
forage for plant i was very into the
outdoors i loved to compete
i liked to create things i loved to sing
and in about adolescence i really got
into speaking on stage everything from
speech and debate team
to you know talent nights to to uh to
singing on stage etc
and so all of those things that i
enjoyed to do
when i was a kid i've woven into my
purpose statements that's one thing sit
down
and make a list yosef of all the things
that you liked to do
when you were a kid that's step one also
write down a list of things that make
time go by very quickly for you now
if you put me in front of a blank page
on a word processor and give me a topic
to write on
i will happily start typing away you
know no
no writer's block anything like that if
you send me in front of that computer
at 10 a.m all right until 1 p.m and feel
as though 20 minutes has passed by
you know and i'll have to set up a
reminder you know do your jumping jacks
stop for your pomodoro breaks you know
do your little eye stretches etc or else
i will just sit there and burn my
eyeballs out
writing you set my wife in front of the
same blank page and she will be
weeping within like 10 minutes because
she hates to write
and uh at the same time if you give her
a canvas and a paintbrush and some oils
she will paint and paint and paint like
nobody's business and create wonderful
art
and it just flows from her whereas for
me i would
sit there and and be throwing the
paintbrush out the window and and
making a complete mess on that canvas
because i just
you know that's not something that puts
me into the zone
art right and so if you identify the
things that make time go by very quickly
for you now
you make another list of that and you'll
find that some of those things
overlap with what you like to do when
you were a kid
you take both of those lists and from
there you begin to hone down
your purpose statement you'll find that
there can be a little bit of guilt
because this idea of self-actualization
dictates that work feels like play to
people who are
self-actualized like time goes by very
quickly things come easy to you
and you don't have to feel guilty about
that right we we have this idea
you know perhaps inspired by the old
school puritanical
or or um you know this this work ethic
that work must be blood and sweat and
tears and as i've alluded to earlier
there are times in your life when you
really will feel
like in order to to pay the bills you
got to put in a little bit of extra work
or even have a have a job on the side
but your your your main career
the thing that you decide to do based on
how your purpose statement evolves
is often something that feels like play
that comes easy to you and it's okay
give yourself permission if you just
excel
at you know let's just pull some random
thing out there at
at uh studio processing on a computer
with music
and creating amazing tunes with whatever
a
guitar and a synthesized piano and a
microphone you you want to start
making music and in jingles and songs
and that just comes super easy to you
and you've always loved music you know
growing up and it comes easy to you now
and makes time go by quickly then
and you know start creating udemy
courses online
and start creating music that you can
you can put on spotify and you know
start an instagram channel and then
you choose the things that come easy to
you you pair that with the things that
make time go by quickly what you enjoyed
to do when you were a little kid
and that's a really good way to start to
piece together
why it is that you're here what your
unique skill set is and
what your true purpose is in life and
then like i mentioned earlier
go out and figure out how to help as
many people as possible love as many
people as possible with that purpose
statement
absolutely i want to recommend to joseph
uh i want to give him permission to like
not have it figured out right now
because it sounds like he's just putting
a lot of pressure on himself
and be curious like it's okay to be
curious and not have it figured out
you're 18 years old the biggest piece of
advice i'll give joseph
to enable him to be able to be curious
and to not have it figured out
avoid debt you're 18 years old you're
gonna be getting credit card offers
uh he talked about going to college um
yeah just try to try to avoid debt as
much as possible because that will free
you up to
to have some time to figure it out
including debt for college
right yeah i think you can leverage that
wisely i mean if you if you get a
zero zero percent on on a on a credit
card and you get a great expense
i'm gonna i am not a dave ramsey cassius
king guy
there i will i will we are i will
leverage debt to the hill
if it allows me to accelerate growth
here's what i'll say there are some
debts that are better
than other debts like that is absolutely
true like you're not going to encourage
him to go get a payday
loan no uh so so i mean i i think we can
agree on that point
um but but yeah i mean as far as uh
debt in general um if he owes somebody
something
it's he's gonna be forced into having
to do something rather than getting to
do something totally yeah
yeah so i fundamentally i believe
there's no such thing as good debt so
personal debt at least we can we can
talk about business debt or government
that those are two different
conversations but in terms of personal
debt
uh especially for someone who's in this
situation where
they are going to keep six figures worth
of potential debt on you
they're you're borrowing against your
your future here and you're not even
sure what you want to do
quite often people will go into five six
figures worth of debt
a great book on this by anthony o'neil
called debt free degree
shows you all the ways that you can
graduate the same degree that you want
to get
without any debt at all and gives you
tons of examples on how to do it
i think ben where we will agree is if
you can get by through a situation
without debt
it's better oh if you can buy without
debt right absolutely
and there are forms of debt that i do
frown you know
university-based tuition debt i think
that's that's horrific i've been
thinking in the
in the medical system it creates a bunch
of doctors who are
overworking seeing patients for 15
minutes trying to pay off their bills
for eight years
and really producing bad medical care as
a result
of a broken educational system for
physicians you know
that's one example of debt creating a
horrific scenario the same could be said
for
you know many other university programs
where students finish and aren't able to
live out their true purpose because
they're simply
just racked to the hilt with debt and
they that you know
and again it's a maslow's hierarchy
scenario you know panic
fear make money figure out how to pay
this off versus living out one's true
purpose
yeah and i think that's what we're
trying to tell joseph here is don't get
yourself in a situation like that right
ma'am
yo so i'm gonna see your copy of our
book everything that remains it's my
favorite thing that we've we've ever
created
uh in terms of our books and it's really
the story of ryan and i leaving the
corporate world
in massive amounts of debt and that's
part of my my big adversion to it is i
made really good money in the corporate
world i spent even better money
on really stupid stuff and and so i had
massive amounts of debt i was
made good money but it was broke and so
we sort of talk about the whole process
that ryan and i went through over that
five year period of
not just decluttering but get our
getting our priorities straight and also
figuring out what direction in which we
wanted to travel
and yosef i think that's the direction
that you're going right now is you're
just trying to figure out
what direction do i want to travel one
last thing i'll tell you
is that you might figure out your
purpose right now and that purpose can
change over time
hopefully you've got six or seven
decades ahead of you right now right
so you could have six or seven different
purposes that you
master over a lifetime but occasionally
we pivot you know someone might be a
a recording artist in their 30s and they
become a producer in their 40s and
and so i hope you enjoy that book it's
called everything that remains if you
like our podcast
i'll send you the audiobook version or
if you want the book book or the ebook
version
we're happy to send those to you as well
yeah that's that's again just
super quick one really important thing
that you just highlighted is the purpose
statement can change
right two years ago mine was to empower
people to live a more adventurous joyful
and fulfilling life and i was steeped in
adventure sports and endurance racing
and just wanted that
i wanted that ability to be able to
inspire people and empower people
through the adventures that i was having
and realized a couple years ago i'm not
going to be a professional athlete
forever i'm not going to be out you know
climbing mountains forever and something
kind of needed to shift you know the
next
chapter in the book that is my life was
approaching
and as that happens your purpose in life
can change some of the same skill sets
and purposes that come naturally to you
can still be woven into that purpose
statement but i
recommend that you sit down and revisit
your purpose statement
at least every year and give yourself
the permission that it might
change as your interests change and as
opportunities arise and
and you know life is a mysterious path
full of zigs and zags to the top of the
mountain
and you know you have to be open
sometimes to changing your purpose
statement or
or turning to the next chapter in life
absolutely otherwise yeah you're going
to you're going to feel stuck
one other thing uh figure out what your
values are we have a free worksheet on
our website theminimalists.com
v there's an essay there called how to
understand your
values and you can just print out that
worksheet we we have i don't know we've
already
identified four different types of
values so your foundational values your
core values your surface values and
the most dangerous values your imaginary
values
the things we pretend are important but
actually aren't the minimalists.com
v for that free worksheet ryan what time
is it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer your text messages
you can text your questions and comments
to 937-202-4654 if you send a text
message to that you also get our monday
morning
minimal maxims we'll send you a text to
your phone every monday we'll never send
you spam or junk or
advertising good alliteration there
monday monday monday morning
what did you say minimal maximums
minimal maxims
uh yeah and so uh speaking of minimal
maxims
this is where we do our best to answer
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response i don't know
if you remember this ben but
um we put the text to these minimal
maxims in the show notes so
people can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if they'd like
also they can find all of our minimal
maxims in one place now another words
maximum.com your answer tweetable
yes yeah yes but you can ramble on and
like sean will fix it up and post
yeah so we'll just talk a bit and then
hopefully we'll find something profound
yeah
or not all right we got a question here
from zoe
how do we let go of long-term
commitments and obligations
especially the things we typically enjoy
but we're just
burnt out on so long-term uh
long-term commitments and obligations
things that we've committed to
right here i'll just give my pity answer
and then maybe ben can expand everything
you've picked up
you can put down i think we don't
realize that all of a sudden we're
traveling up mount everest with uh
150 pounds worth of gear on our back
and it's we picked it all up one ounce
at a time too
right and not realizing like oh man i've
got
so much and this weight can be literal
you can have a lot of stuff
but there can be all of these other
weights too the obligations and
commitments
that zoe's talking about here yes
uh anthony demello in his book awareness
sums it up quite nicely
when he says that we should be able to
look at anything in life that we derive
pleasure from
and say to that object that item that
person that thing that activity
i derive pleasure from you but i am not
attached to you for my happiness i do
not depend upon you
for my happiness if there's anything in
your life that you can't say that
to without feeling a little pit in your
stomach and and a little bit of
resistance to saying that then that is
something that has become
an unhealthy attachment or a pleasure
that you're actually relying upon
for your happiness so i would read
anthony demelo's book awareness very
quick read
simple to get through but it really
teaches you how to release a lot of
those attachments how to release a lot
of those pleasures and
i've found that that for me in terms of
cleaning up the clutter
that a big part of it a big part of that
clutter
is related to what another author
napoleon hill
dictates in his book outwitting the
devil outwitting the devil describes
this so-called hypnotic trance
right these rituals these habits these
routines that we set up for ourselves
that we become very addicted to
throughout the day and we have this
dopaminergic response to
you know i've got my stretch routine on
fitness you know i got my stretch
routine i got my breath routine i got
this workout i got that workout oh i
just found out about the saunas now i
gotta do the sauna and
oh somebody's talking about cold
thermogenesis so i need to figure out
how to throw that in the room
by the end of the day there's all these
things to do
right but you can get drawn into it as
just like this hypnotic trance of
rituals and routines
and habits and you need to be able to
step back and identify those things that
you're just doing because they've become
a habit that you feel like you have to
do versus those things that are actually
necessary and crucial for you to feel
really fulfilled at the end of the day
and you'd be surprised at how few things
there are
that are actually truly necessary versus
those things that become
mildly addictive habits yeah you know
this question makes me think about what
you were
talking about earlier with examining our
purpose and being willing to change that
i think the same thing goes with our
commitments
maybe you know on a yearly basis you
look down and look at all your
commitments
and ask yourself which ones are worth
keeping and which ones
might have to go what you might have to
change my pithy answer is this a
meaningful life overflows with joy
not commitments so when i think about
that uh when i was reading this question
i also thought about how
a commitment should ultimately lead you
to something joyful
you know if uh i know there are certain
commitments in life that you know we've
got to go to work and pay the bills
but ultimately that is leading to
something joyful but if you've committed
to something
that is uh completely non-joyful
um i give you permission to let it go so
all right before we get into our
listener tips on our added value segment
today
both of which i think you're going to
enjoy but before we get into that
in fact i want to talk to you you had
this thing about the news ryan oh yeah
so we're going to get the bad news well
i've got the good news about the bad
news
or the bad the good news on the good
news
about the bad news we're going to get to
that it's our added value segment but
first we got a bunch of surprise
questions like
what are your thoughts on healing
practices like reiki acupuncture and
hypnosis
what other non-traditional practices
might you recommend what daily rituals
make ben
feel at peace what makes him feel the
most
alive how do you prioritize what matters
most how do you avoid negative self-talk
how do our boundaries help limit our
mental and emotional clutter
also we're going to discuss parenting
homeschooling versus
unschooling we're going to talk about
ben's most useful gadgets
a lot of things that he uses
intentionally to amplify or enhance or
improve his life
we're also going to talk about some of
the sex tips that he has in
his book boundless but he goes way
beyond what he talks about in the book
we're going to have him talk about a lot
of things on the maximal episode
plus a bunch more questions for ben
greenfield if you want to hear all that
check out our maximal episode this week
on the minimalist private podcast guys
it's a completely
separate endeavor and it's just two
bucks totally separate podcast
and it's the best way for us to fund
this podcast it's the most honest way
for the minimalist to earn
income you know we don't do
advertisements we think advertisements
suck so we make money if
and only if you find value in and
support what we
create just head on over to
theminimalists.com
support to subscribe you'll also get a
personal link so that our private
podcast plays
in your favorite podcast app ryan what
else you got for us this week here are
some voicemail comments and tips from
our listeners check them out hi my name
is katie from sioux falls south dakota
i was really close with my grandma who
passed away probably about 12 years ago
and i ended up with a lot of her jewelry
because that was what i played with
as a kid and as i've gone through my
minimizing
journey i've decided to keep one thing
and it's her class ring from 1948.
i wear it every day in fact that's too
small now i can't even take it off and
everything else i have let go and that
way i can always keep her with me
however i don't have the burden of all
of her other jewelry
hi my name is adrian and i'm from
raleigh north carolina um
you guys were talking about meditation
and how
it could possibly lead you to a dark
place
if you have never done that before and
you spent like maybe a long time
in meditation and i just have a lot of
insight into that i just wanted to
share that yes it could bring yourself
to a dark place however for me
personally
i was ever able to uncover a lot of
traumatic events that i've suppressed
since childhood through meditation
and although that led me to a very dark
place initially
it led me to where i am now which is a
much happier
version of myself so i just wanted to
share that for listeners who
may be turned off by that idea um i
think that it is worth it
so to meditate all right y'all thanks
again to ben greenfield for joining us
today check out his new book
boundless we'll put a link to that in
the show notes we'll also put a link to
his podcast
ben greenfield fitness and for our added
value this week ryan
you came in here today this morning
before we started recording yeah
and you're like i read this headline
just messed up my day
messed up my morning man i should have
i usually check news later in the day i
don't know why i checked it this morning
but yeah i read a headline uh it totally
threw me off i had to come in here
seeking some advice from friends to help
me get over this headline and i think
the problem isn't the news per se
it's the news media and what the media
is doing
in fact because the news we won't have
to talk about it because it's a rather
partisan thing
but what's happening is they're actually
reporting on non-news most of the time
right the news that you came in with was
pure speculation
right from and by the way what we did is
we went to like the most conservative
organ
and we went to the most liberal organ
and they were both reporting on the same
news right the the same non-news the
same
speculation and so my knee-jerk reaction
is well let's just ignore the news
and okay that might be better than than
constantly being bombarded by the news
but i think i have something better so
my added value today
is a quarterly journal called american
affairs and it's a policy journal
and they do a really good job writing
long form essays
interesting about policies i love that
and by the way it's
usually and it mixes both sides we
always look for like
well i want the conservative take and
the liberal take they actually take
very thoughtful pieces from all sides of
the political spectrum
conservative commentators centrist
commentators
liberal commentators and they
get deep into nuance on policy so i've
learned a whole lot more about policy
on the state level on a national level
on international policy
i've become educated instead of being
beaten by the fire hose of news
and so i love it i would encourage you
to get a subscription to american
affairs i'll send you the link to it
we'll put a link to it in the show notes
as well
it's a quarterly journal it shows up
it's printed it's it's a little bit
bigger than one of our books this is
everything that remains here
but it comes and it's it feels like a
book every time i get it
and it it reads with all of these
different essays and they're they're
thick they're probably 200 pages wow but
i go through and what's beautiful about
it the cover lists every essay that's in
in that particular one so i'll just go
through and say oh wow that one
about california's tax policy and how we
got here that one looks really
interesting
it's about the the potential feudal
state of
of california or there was another one
about
environmentalism or whatever but they
really get into the nuances
this sounds like really boring news but
in fact
isn't that the important news exactly
and the problem is as we look for
non-boring news which is the least
important of what we should be reading
and these are well written the stuff
that you're reading we don't even care
about the
the writing anymore right no and we
don't care about the nuance point of
view and
and it actually takes these long form
essays to be able to
to dive into the pros and the cons and
for people to be able to
to steel man their own arguments you
can't do that in a
headline or even a 400 word op-ed
these are much more intelligent much
more
of a deep dive on important topics and
yes it may not be as
sensational but there's so much more
satisfying it's eating that meal
where you feel nerd you feel nourished
by the end of it not the piece of cake
that they threw at your face that's what
a great analogy
yeah because because after eating that
cake i feel like crap right
ruins my morning i shouldn't have eaten
cake this morning so check out american
affairs and real quick
for right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of
the minimalist we have a free ebook for
you it's called financial freedom it'll
help you get together a
sort of budgeting plan but it's the five
steps that ryan and i
took so that we could become debt free
and financially free and we put it all
into one
ebook and we're giving it to you for
free no strings attached you don't have
to give us a dollar later or anything
uh it's just the minimalists.com
resources it's on our resources page
you can download it from there the
minimalists.com
slash resources the free ebook is called
financial
freedom you can follow the minimalists
on facebook twitter and instagram
at the minimalists come to one of our
live podcast shows visit the
minimalists.com
tour to find a city near you if you have
a question comment or minimalism tip for
our podcast email a voice memo to
podcast
minimalists.com you can comment on this
episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes and your inbox
sign up for our email list over at
theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple sunday
emails and if you leave here today with
just
one message we hope it's this
love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
every little thing you think that you
need
every little thing you think that you
need
little thing that's just feeding your
greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it